s
redoublent d'ardeur pour se
préparer à la prochaine tempête.
- Des pelles et des bottes
de caoutchouc. Cette famille
a décidé de passer son samedi
les deux pieds dans la boue
pour prêter main-forte à un ami.
- La personne en question,
c'est Rick, un entraîneur
de volleyball local.
Une cinquantaine de personnes
sont venues l'aider.
- Il habite tout près de
l'endroit où la digue a cédé;
le pont devant chez lui a été
emporté par le courant.
- Sa maison n'a pas ét
épargnée. Il avait de l'eau
jusqu'aux hanches, si bien
qu'il a dû se rendre chez
son voisin en canot.
Alors c'est cette digue,
qui protège les terres agricoles
d'Abbotsford, qui a cédé
cette semaine. Des camionscommea
digue depuis plus de 24 heures,
sans arrêt. Ils y emmènent
de la terre, de la pierre pour
tenter de colmater la brèche.
Il faut y arriver avant
que la pluie ne revienne.
- La vallée du Fraser et le sud
de la province, déjà éprouvés,
pourraient recevoir jusqu'à
une centaine de millimètres
de précipitations
en début de semaine.
D'ici là, les efforts
s'organisent; un nouveauinininis
est arrivé aujourd'hui.
Ils apportent entre autres
des hélicoptères pour acheminer
du carburant et de la nourriture
à des communautés
si le temps le permet.
- C'est que souvent avec la
pluie vient le couvert de nuag
et la diminution de visibilité.
Fait que certaines places
surtout dans les montagnes,
pour ce qui est des
hélicoptères, ils ne sont pascas
montagnes, donc ils doivent
voler à vue. Fait que si la
météo est moins bonne, ça se
peut qu'ils ne peuvent
tout simplement pas
mais je peux vous garantir
qu'ils vont faire leur possible
pour y aller.
- Mais aujourd'hui, l'heure est
au nettoyage. Rick se prépare
aux prochaines intempéries.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Abbotsf